So, Charlie, what's your
greatest fear?
Well, Charlie, I'd have to say
that my greatest fear is death.
Oh...is that what you're
going to talk about?
Yeah, yeah it is.
Okay. I'll leave you to it.
It's not a particularly original fear,
sorry about that,
but, you know, that's not
really how it works, is it?
You don't pick the most interesting thing to--
I'm afraid of guacamole. Ohh!
Oh, you're so quirky you and your--
no I'm just afraid of what I'm afraid of.
For something like guacamole,
if you are genuinely afraid of guacamole,
by the way, I'm sorry for
making light of your fears,
but if you are afraid of guacamole,
it's not the worst thing in the world
because you can always just like, you know,
not go to Mexican restaurants.
Guacamole isn't inevitable.
It's not gonna take you in the night.
I don't know why the idea of a Guacamole
Grim Reaper is so funny to me, but it just is.
But death--
(LAUGHTER)
Oh no! Guacamole--
Nobody else thinks that is as
funny as I do, I'm sure of it.
But death, right,
death is inevitable.
There's nothing that I can do about the fact
that one day I'm am gonna die.
It would be useful if I believed
in any kind of afterlife, I don't,
so my fate, I think, is gonna
be the big nothing,
the big, black, dark void of
no consciousness, of no anything,
and that is what terrifies me.
That void is the only thing
in my life, at the moment,
that really makes me
want to poo my pants.
Given that I can't really help
how I feel, what do I do?
Honestly, the first
thing I go to is,
"Well, you never know.
Technology these days, in 20 or 30 years,
they could have done immortality.
We could all live forever.
Wouldn't that be lovely?"
No, it wouldn't.
For one thing, Earth is kind of
reaching capacity anyway right now,
and I'm pretty sure if some
scientist invented immortality,
most people would
want a piece of that,
and I think that might
result in too many humans,
which would be a
big problem.
And there's also the
factor of, at some point,
the universe is going
to end, so you will die.
Like you can't exist if there's
no place for you to exist in.
After that, I think, "Well if I am going
to die, at least I can live forever
in the memories of the
people who love me, right?"
No. Even if you did the coolest thing
that anyone has ever done ever,
the people who remember you,
they're gonna die as well.
Everyone is gonna die.
No one is gonna be around to remember
anyone eventually, so...(SIGH)
then what makes me feel
better, weirdly enough,
is thinking about my funeral,
my fantasy funeral.
I'm aware of the fact that
this is not gonna happen,
but, ideally, I'd kinda like my body
to be shot into the sun.
I don't know. I just really like idea of
all of my friends and family, you know,
sitting around, wearing black, being somber,
my mum with a little tear in her eye--
I died before my mum did, oh!
But everyone, you know, just hanging out in a
graveyard, looking up at a giant rocket
and then seeing that rocket being shot
into a boiling hot ball of plasma.
That would just be
awesome, wouldn't it?
Realistically, though, what can
you do with a fear of death?
If there's one thing I've learned
about being scared over the years,
given that I am YouTube's
resident expert on the topic,
it's that if you are afraid of something,
it means that thing is pretty important.
And what's important to me it's,
you know, it's obvious, really.
It's living the fullest and
best life I possibly can,
making the most of the time
I have left on this planet
so that when I finally am
on my deathbed,
I can look back at everything
I've done and be like,
"Yeah, pretty good job.
Well done, Charlie. That's it."
And then, you know, black
void of nothingness.
Anyway...um...that's what I've
been thinking about recently.
See you next week. Lol.
That's not going to happen.
Don't even. I'll be around.
Don't you worry about me.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
TOY WINDING
NERF GUN BEING SHOT
NERF GUN STOPS SHOOTING
So worth it.
The fear is probably
worse for me--
Jesus, I'm making another video
about something I'm scared of.
Just, let's just get on
with it, shall we?
What's your greatest
fear, Charlie?
Uh...I guess my favorite--
(LAUGHING) My favorite fear?
My favorite fear?
My all time favorite fear--